yesterday we had a nearly 14 hour
live stream of the second day of joe
biden's supreme court nominee judge
katanji brown jackson's
confirmation hearing during which she
was asked about 30 minutes of questions
by each
of the full group is 22 senators on the
judiciary committee i believe they got
to 20 and then the last two were going
to go this morning and we're going to
get to some clips of what was asked and
we're going to talk about all of that
but before doing any of that i think
it's important to take an objective look
at
how qualified judge jackson is and by
any any any measure
any objective measure
judge katanji brown jackson
is
or would be one of the most qualified
supreme court justices in recent history
and this is not going by
uh vague
ideology-based opinions or anything
subjective merely looking at the facts
of her experience
it is hard to find a more qualified
supreme court justice recently now i
know many of you as we get into this are
going to say but hold on a second david
if amy coney barrett can be on the court
if kavanaugh can be on the court
why is this even a conversation and of
course you would be completely correct
to frame it in those terms but because
it is worth actually thinking about the
experience of a potential supreme court
justice we're going to look at it and
there's a very good chart out which
looks at the rece the current justices
and compares judge jackson's experience
and what you find when you look at it is
that she checks
more boxes than do any of the justices
currently on the court
when you look at
whether she went to an ivy league law
school which i don't think is the the
standard by which we should evaluate
qualifications but one of the things
that many say is well where where was
the legal education
all of the justices currently on the
court other than barrett went to an ivy
league law school and so did judge
jackson
when you look at which justices were
clerks on the supreme court clarence
thomas alito and sotomayor were not the
other uh justices on the court were and
judge jackson was a supreme court clerk
great
in terms of who was a public defender
none of them none of them judge jackson
actually brings unique experience or
would bring unique experience to the
court by virtue of having been a public
defender none of the nine current
justices did that as a job
um only justice breyer
who would be uh replaced by judge
jackson
was on a sentencing commission and
indeed judge katanji brown jackson was
on a sentencing commission only judge
sotomayor of the justices currently on
the court was a district judge
judge jackson has that experience in her
background as well
and currently all justices other than
elena kagan
were judges on courts of appeals
and indeed
judge jackson was a judge
on the court of appeals now i so so the
objective case is
as or more qualified
than any of the justices currently on
the court now i think there's one
interesting thing to talk about here um
you and i might look at the experience
of judge jackson and say wow that's
that's amazing and it's actually
fascinating that public defender
experience
and sentencing commission experience and
district judge experience that's unique
that's a unique level of experience
nobody on the court right now
has had experience in those three areas
but there's a liability that comes with
that which we learned about yesterday
during the hearing
and it is that it provides a significant
amount of fodder
for which she can be attacked well why
did you do this specific sentence in
this case
or why did you rule in this particular
way why did you defend this particular
client even though lawyers defend
clients that's what they do and the
analogy here would be imagine that i ran
for something
you and i might say well you know what's
what's great is i have over 10 years of
talking about so many different issues
you can just kind of look up and see
what my thoughts are but the truth is
that if you did let's call it
a political colonoscopy or you know a
political body cavity search and you
went through everything i've ever said
on the show you know hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours you would
without a doubt be able to find things
that don't represent number one the what
i would call the best of my show
that might be opinions which have
changed because either
my opinions have changed or there's
different information that has now come
out which has led me to have to revise
opinions so without a doubt if i were to
run for something
although i see it as a positive thing
that i have this long track record of
people being able to see the evolution
of my views you would be able to troll
that and find things to take out of
context or isolate that i without a
doubt would make me look bad i'm i
it would make me look bad and along the
same way although you and i might say
wow public defender experience and
sentencing commission experience and
district judge experience that's
unbelievable what we saw yesterday
during the first day of questions asked
to judge jackson
and what we are already seeing today
during the second day of questions which
is underway right now as we are at as we
are recording today's show is that it
also can serve as
a sort of catalyst or as a basis
to focus in extraordinarily narrowly
uh on particular decisions and take them
out of context and and whatever else one
other thing um there was a lot of uh
concern yesterday from republican
senators about
sentences given by judge jackson on what
now i want to be clear some people call
it child porn i don't think that's the
right word
because pornography
is almost always legal and involving
consenting adults and is a business to
some degree
to just put child on that and to pretend
it what we're talking about is
child exploitation right i mean we're
not talking about filmmakers when we
talk about people
producing or or whatever these images
but for what they call child porn which
i don't think is the right term for it
they talked a lot about her departures
from
the maximum penalties as sort of a
liability but the truth is the people
doing that like for example republican
senator josh hawley he has previously
supported many judicial candidates uh
that
departed from the maximum sentencing
numerous times so they focused in on
that
uh but significant hypocrisy there so
that's the qualifications net let's now
go to some of the questioning
there was endless
uh there were endless instances
yesterday during the first day of
questions being asked of uh joe biden's
supreme court nominee judge katanji
brown jackson
examples of bizarre
inappropriate and cartoonishly odd
questions asked of her and i'm going to
show you some of them now before we look
at the first one and the first one's
going to be lindsey graham asking the
judge to rate her level of religiosity i
think it's important to understand
that in some general sense these
hearings
are basically a sideshow
99
percent of the time
every senator has already decided how
they're going to vote on the nomination
they've already uh they already know the
answers to the questions that they're
asking and typically you will see
senators from the party that nominated
the candidate the the nominee
um just throw what we what call throwing
bouquets at each other praise talk to us
about how great your parents are stuff
like that and then
those in the opposite party will ask uh
antagonistic questions now there are
substantive antagonistic questions an
example would be if i had to say who was
the best republican yesterday in terms
of asking questions it was ben sasse
they were
respectful questions
that seemed material
to the role of being a supreme court
justice lindsey graham marsha blackburn
ted cruz an absolute and total joke
let's start with the first clip here's
lindsey graham asking what religion are
you and how religious are you
what faith are you by the way
senator i am um
protestant
okay um
non-denominational okay
could you fairly judge a catholic
senator i have a record of i don't think
the answer would be judging everyone you
can i'm just and by the way
every republican senator other than ben
sasse
relentlessly interrupting judge jackson
relentlessly
this question because
how important
is your faith to you
senator personally
my faith is very important
but as you know
there's no religious test in the
constitution under under article six
how important
is your faith to you later asking her to
rate her religiosity from 1 to 10.
it's 2022 guys it is 2022 and lindsey
graham is asking this question during a
supreme court hearing
ted cruz making a mockery of the entire
hearing
by asking
about racist babies
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist
senator
the pause is real
i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are
racist or though they are
not valued or though they are less than
that they are victims that they are
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that
now importantly these are not issues on
which
a supreme court justice
normally has to have an opinion i mean
what
it is not really for a lawyer or judge
to determine whether babies are racist
it's not a particular topic i've thought
about too much but if i wanted an answer
to it i wouldn't go to a supreme court
justice
marsha blackburn maybe the most
weaponized of all of the republican
senators on the judiciary committee
asks
are there differences between men and
women
again
supreme court justice what do you agree
with justice ginsburg that there are
physical differences between men and
women that are enduring
um
senator
respectfully i
am not familiar with that particular
quote or case okay so it's hard for me
to
okay comment as to what now that was
another theme where republican senators
would say judge jackson
are you familiar with the this book and
then this article about the book no i've
never read the book and i've never read
the article okay which of the two do you
agree with
the entire day uh here's one more clip
of marsha blackburn asking can you
define
woman
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition now this is this this rings
very uh hits ho close to home for me
because when i was on the jessie lee
peterson show
in out in california a couple years ago
he asked me to define man he said what
is a man and i said i do politics i
don't i don't do definitions i know this
isn't that i'm not the dictionary um and
it was like this all day now
interestingly despite all of the
qualifications of judge jackson
last night tucker carlson on fox news
was still wondering where
are judge jackson's lsat scores legal
minds
one way to know one indication would be
her lsat scores
the lsat is not a knowledge test it
measures logic and reasoning ability and
no one doubts it's an accurate measure
of those things which predicts legal
skills and that's why top law firms law
schools have long used that test
so how did kintaji brown jackson do in
the lsat so and by the way kentaji guys
i mean listen um for years it's not
kamala it's
camilla camella kamala
et cetera et cetera and now in the last
day i've heard from these right-wingers
kentaji which is not her name
catania
and a whole bunch of others at what
point do we wonder whether they're doing
it on purpose and i don't know the
answer um so tucker remains concerned
about the lsat scores humiliation
complete and total humiliation from
these right wingers
and by every
sensible
estimation
judge jackson will have no problem
getting on the court let me know your
thoughts find me on twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is funded and made
possible by you and i would love for you
to sign up and support the program at
joinpacman.com republican senator mike
braun yesterday said he would be okay
putting the issue of interracial
marriage back to the states rather than
the supreme court decision which
bans bans on interracial marriage
holding he would be fine canceling that
and letting states decide do you want
interracial marriage to be legal or do
you want interracial marriage to be
illegal this understandably created a
firestorm because it's a crazy thing to
say let's look at the clip here is uh
mike braun so you would be okay with the
supreme court leaving the question of
interracial marriage to the states
yes i think that that's something that
uh if you're not wanting the supreme
court to weigh in on issues like that
you're not going to be able to have your
cake and eat it too i think that's
hypocritical
about griswold versus connecticut
well you can list a whole host of issues
so
he very clearly heard the question
and the point here is
many republicans like mike braun like to
say
the supreme court really shouldn't
decide about all sorts of things the
supreme court shouldn't decide that
abortion generally speaking should be
legal it should just be up to the states
the supreme court shouldn't decide that
states aren't allowed to ban same-sex
marriage and so it's a reasonable
question which is that would you also
apply to this to interracial marriage
should states be allowed to ban into
racial marriage he clearly heard the
question and answered it unfortunately
for him this was a completely outrageous
thing to say
and he had to later walk it back
claiming he didn't hear the question
braun walks back remark criticizing the
supreme court ruling that legalized
interracial marriage and you've got to
go to the bottom of the article on the
hill in a statement to the hill later
tuesday bronze said he misunderstood the
question as posed
earlier during a virtual press
conference i misunderstood a line of
questioning that ended up being about
interracial marriage let me be clear on
that issue there is no question the
constitution prohibits discrimination of
any kind based on race that is not
something that is even up for debate i
condemn racism in any form at all levels
and by any states entities or
individuals
so um uh claiming claiming he just
didn't even really know what what he was
being asked now there is a very
important legal conversation to have
about when should states be left to
decide about whatever and not all of
these issues are created equal when you
say well leave states to decide about
abortion well okay the supreme court put
in place this undue burden test that's
the the basis of casey casey is the
court the decision in addition to roe v
wade
uh you've got casey
and there the court put in place this
undue burden standard which says that
abortion restrictions
are unconstitutional
if the purpose or effect places a
substantial obstacle in the path of
women who want to get an abortion so
that that's one decision and one sort of
framework uh leave states to decide
about do you have to have car insurance
most states say you do
virginia and new hampshire have
different rules like in new hampshire
car insurance isn't mandatory
but if you're driving causes damages
then you're liable and that's a decision
that a state has made
leave states to decide about should
marijuana be legal and can be purchased
just like cigarettes or alcohol well for
now states can decide about that if the
federal government were to
in some way
fully legalize marijuana um
reschedule it okay then you would sort
of have a fight when it comes to the
decision about interracial marriage the
supreme court said no no no there's a
constitutional basis here equal the
equal protection clause
if properly scrutinized as the supreme
court did
doesn't allow
states to ban interracial marriage you
can't leave it to the states because of
the federal supremacy clause and the
fact that banning interracial marriage
would violate the federal constitution
so the framework is very different than
some of these other decisions so the
point here is
even if there is a legitimate debate to
be had about what should states have to
decide about
interracial marriage is outside of that
and uh i don't believe mike braun
misheard it nor misunderstood it i think
he just gave the wrong answer it was
just wrong and it was crazy and he got
called out for it and he had to walk it
back
uh during the first day of judge katanji
brown jackson's confirmation hearings
and by the first day i mean monday
the former president donald trump
attempted to do some counter-programming
uh wherein he gave an interview to fox
business host
stuart varney and this was a very
dangerous and corrosive interview and
we're going to look at a couple of clips
of it and there is one segment here
where donald trump provocatively wants
to talk about the n-word but it's not
the n-word you think of he's talking
about nuclear or nuclear depending on
your preferred pronunciation here is
donald trump talking about putin
and nuclear well in hope to god you
never have to use it because it would be
that would be the tragedy of all
tragedies but if we didn't have it we
couldn't talk but i listened to him
constantly using the n-word that's the
n-word and he's constantly using it the
nuclear word right and we never
talk if we say oh he's a nuclear power
so trump there i i don't know if he
thinks it's clever or what to refer to
nuclear as the n-word but stuart varney
is visibly perplexed by it then stuart
varney made a big mistake
stuart varney tried asking donald trump
about policy and as you know and as i
know and as many of our viewers know
when you ask trump about policy you do
not get an answer it's almost satirical
at this point
there's this discussion about whether we
should send jets mig jets to help the
ukrainian air force would you send in
that kind of help
well maybe even more
to be honest with you and i'm not mr
president
whatever the one that would have stayed
out let me just explain that
putin is saying things like
don't you dare send anything in in the
meantime he's killing thousands of
thousands of people
so he's acting like we're an aggressor
if we send in some old 44 year old plane
that probably gets shot out of the sky
pretty quickly
and he's acting like we were terrible
people if we do that
but he's killing tens of thousands of
people far more than they're reporting
you don't knock down those buildings and
blow up those buildings and they say two
people were injured slightly yeah so the
question was would you send in the jets
and trump says i might even send more
and then the question is well what
exactly would you send and trump's off
on a tangent he later is able varney is
able to get trump back on track
and then
there's the question of well okay what
exactly would you do and trump says well
i might send nuclear subs to intimidate
nobody knows where they are
and you should say look you if you
mention that word one more time
and we're going to send them over and
we'll be coasting back and forth up and
down your coast you can't let this
tragedy continue you can't let these
these thousands of people die it's going
to be hundreds of thousands and maybe
millions of people by the time it ends
right so i guess trump is at the same
time that he has been very hesitant to
criticize vladimir putin and at the same
time that he delayed sending military
aid to ukraine because he wanted dirt on
biden he's also saying he would be more
aggressive than joe biden but at the
same time saying he would have kept us
out of war so as you can tell this is
what we might call in the academic world
a very complicated text uh if you would
keep us out of wars why would you be be
doing more aggression than joe biden
it's all sort of confusing
later the topic goes and this is a very
dangerous topic for the former president
climate change and varney asks a
very specific question and trump gives a
very bizarre answer
that i don't even think ever took a
course in
uh the environment is the climate
is the climate changing because of human
activity
in my opinion uh you have a thing called
weather and you go up and you go down if
you look into the 1920s they were
talking about uh global freezing okay in
other words the globe was going to
freeze
and then they go global warming then
they couldn't use that because the
temperatures were actually quite cool
and many different things so that now
they just talk about climate change the
climate's always been changing okay so
and as we know donald trump is one of
the foremost uh authorities on climate
and as well as on renewable energy right
i mean you guys remember his expertise
there the noise causes cancer yeah uh so
um lastly in this just a very it was
sort of like a subdued low energy trump
he almost sounded slightly ill maybe he
had just woken up
uh
varney asks trump
what should be the
uh
uh let me see how i can trump says the
focus for republicans in 2022 and 2024
should be how joe biden stole stole the
election from him in 2020. if we go into
2022 the elections and we by the way
2024
and you're still looking back to the
election of 2020
and saying that you really won
i don't know that's very good for you or
the republican party it's not a comment
on that
well i yeah i actually think it is good
for me and i think if we don't
uh
put out all of the crooked things that
we know what they are
that you won't win in 22 and you won't
win in 24. i think what trump means is
if if we don't keep talking about that
people will forget about me we don't get
to it so i think it's the opposite
actually and i talked nothing about
nobody talks more about the future you
think that 2022.
you think that 2022 and 2024 are all
about the 2020 election right no no no i
think for us to win the election we have
to know how they cheated because
otherwise they'll cheat again and we do
know how they cheated okay and the
republicans but so then why do you need
to talk about it right i mean it doesn't
make any sense what this is this is
really just
it needs to be about me for the next
three years and democrats should but
they won't republicans have to do
something about it or they're going to
be very disappointed and nobody talks
more about the future than i do but you
have to learn from history also and you
can't let it happen again so right so
right that would be a real shame as
donald trump likes to say so a very
strange interview and uh sort of an
attempt at counter programming
the confirmation hearings of judge
katanji brown jackson there it is we'll
have the clips on our instagram which
you can find at davidpakmanshow and i'll
have more information for you about
upcoming events that we'll be covering
very soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
some of you may be familiar with the
right wing musical artist who goes by
the name kid rock kid rock
has developed a friendship of some kind
with the former president donald trump
including playing golf etc he was
recently interviewed by tucker carlson
the the interview's bizarre tucker
carlson's appearance and demeanor during
the interview are
extremely strange but the big revelation
from the interview is kid rock claims
that donald trump would ask him about
foreign policy advice and about tweets
that he was imminently going to send out
related to relationships with foreign
countries and the like now we're going
to look at kid rock
uh explaining this to tucker carlson but
i think one one important thing to keep
in mind is
i doubt that kid rock was the least
qualified person to give donald trump
advice on policy i like did it's
outrageous that kid rock was put in that
position but there were probably equally
unqualified people and at least kid rock
seems to recognize how absurd it was for
him to be pulled into this stuff so
let's jump into the interview here meet
trump
let me trump oh
god at the white house it was sarah
palin the white house and i'm sarah
palin asked him to uh it was friendly
with her and
early right when he got elected he
invited her to dinner and said bring
some interesting people right so she
said she called me and and ted up to
nugent and was like hell yeah ended up
there we ended up becoming buddies and
spent a lot of time on the golf course
now and
it's really weird get phone calls from
and stuff it's it's kind of mind-blowing
what's he like to play golf with
awesome
so much fun really why
he just knows how to have fun doesn't
take it too seriously yeah you know he's
engaging
it's just you're just cutting it up just
open with politics and i was there with
him one day when he ended the caliphate
right he wanted that incred the one day
when the cat the the entire caliphate
ended you guys remember that day right
about a tweet and it was like
i don't like to speak out of school i
hope i'm not but it was something like
he's like
tell him like yeah the tweet was and i'm
paraphrasing but it was like you know if
you ever join the cow fate you know and
try to do this you're going to be dead
he goes what are you thinking
awesome right yeah tweet that out i was
like i can't add anything better than
that but then it comes out it's very
it's reworded and more political and
like you know a little politically
correct and i'm like just being
brilliant we're looking at maps
i'm like you know i'm like am i supposed
to be like you know
so
uh very very trustworthy that trump with
uh classified insensitive information as
we all know remember hillary's emails
and all that
i make dirty records sometimes but
i do it here you didn't think you'd have
a hand what do you think we should do
about north korea i'm like
what
i don't think i'm qualified to answer
this
at least kid rock knew he wasn't
qualified at least at least and tucker
just finds it hilarious and it's funny
how if any of these types of folks
had like an inside line to joe biden and
the oval office and were even on the
periphery of anything substantive
tucker wouldn't be laughing the way he's
laughing he'd be calling for an
impeachment
[Laughter]
how does he how does he see you're still
playing golf with him down in florida
yeah yeah how's he seeing what's that
how's he seem
he seems great
he seems great you know after the
election it was you know a little you
know a little different there and
but
he's still the same guy
he sits down he just cuts it up
just starts cutting it up it's just how
sharp he is is incredible and you can
see now if you watch
a joe biden interview and you watch a
trump interview you're just like there's
there's no comparison now that is true i
mean you you guys remember all of the
incredibly astute and articulate and and
just the clarity with which trump would
speak and god bless
the united states take a look at the
oranges of the investigation the noise
causes cancer right you guys are you
remember all of that stuff and just
always just so clear and concise and it
all made sense so this is pretty
dangerous and it also exposes the double
standard of course that like i said
um if i mean listen during the
presidency
jared and ivanka everywhere ivanka
sitting in for rex tillerson once at a
meeting
at least once that we know about
if
you know
hunter biden if hillary clinton had been
president uh
and and her daughter had been in any way
involved in the presidency these very
people would be going
bananas
arguing this is criminal and it's all
gonna and meanwhile you know kid rock
ivanka jared kushner what they just
don't care and it's uh yet another one
of these incredible double standards hey
this is this is almost beyond parody
um
donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows
is being investigated for voter fraud
and mark meadow's wife appears to have
incorrectly illegally fraudulently
filled out voter registrations you've
got to see this this is just
unbelievable after arguing for you know
six months that democrats were going to
cheat and all of these voter
registration things all this different
stuff and then claiming the election was
stolen by joe biden
salon is now reporting mark meadows
under investigation for alleged voter
fraud in north carolina
macon county d.a
a meadows ally
refers potential prosecution of trump's
ex-chief of staff
to the attorney general this is
unbelievable
meadows who helped spread trump's
debunked voter fraud claims may have
committed voter fraud himself in 2020.
trump's former top aide and his wife
debbie registered to vote in what has
been called a dive trailer in a remote
rural area meadows does not appear to
have spent a single night there
according to the report local news
outlet wral later reported that meadows
and his wife voted via absentee ballots
in north carolina in 2020 sparking a
state investigation state attorney
general josh stein's office asked the
state bureau of investigation to
investigate alongside the board of
elections at the conclusion we'll review
their findings
um
this he
he seems to have done the thing
which they said everybody else on the
democratic side is doing meadows listed
the scally mountain mobile home address
in a voter registration field that asks
for the residential address where you
physically live
mark and debbie meadows sold their prior
north carolina home when meadows joined
the trump administration meadows is also
registered to vote in virginia where
they own a condo
the former owner of the mobile home told
wral they had rented the property to
meadow's family but said the former
trump aide never spent a night down
there and that meadow's wife only stayed
for a night or two
then there's a report
in the washington post about deborah
meadows debra meadows appears to have
filed
three false voter forms
look at this
look at this on her one-stop application
provided this week by the north carolina
board of elections to the fact-checker
debra meadows certified she resided in a
14 by 62 foot mountaintop mobile home
for at least 30 days even though she did
not live there at the top of the form is
a notice that quote fraudulently or
falsely completing this form is a class
one felony uh-oh
this form is the latest in a string of
revelations concerning the former chief
of staff
who echoed trump's claims false claims
of election fraud in 2020
and his wife
the new yorker first reported that mark
and debra meadows submitted voter
registration forms listing their home as
a mobile home with a rusted metal roof
that sold for a hundred and five
thousand dollars even though they never
lived there
north carolina officials announced that
meadows is under investigation for
potential fraud now this this is like
the key part here
um the fact checkers reporting shows
that in 2020 debra meadows signed three
forms a voter registration form an
absentee ballot request for her husband
and the one stop application that warned
of legal consequences if falsely
completed and signed she also cast a
ballot in a 2020 primary runoff using an
address that was no longer valid for
voting
meadows appears to have signed a voter
registration form he did not vote in the
primary guys the calls are coming from
inside the house you know it has been a
decade now at least
of republicans regularly accusing others
of the things they are actually doing
and it's almost like a technique it's
it's like an investigative technique for
us if we hear from republicans
that hillary would not be trustworthy
with sensitive private and classified
information or email
we should at least explore
whether it is they who cannot be trusted
and of course we find out jared's using
private email for white house business
ivanka's using private email from white
for white house business trump is
spilling secrets to a russian spy
recruiter in the oval office trump is
eating papers
flushing papers 10 to 15 times
reportedly
if they're saying that democrats are
doing it we should at least investigate
whether it is actually them that are
doing it when they say well
we are going to uh have democrats do all
sorts of voter fraud
well we should be really careful that
you're going to do the voter fraud and
that you're going to spread lies about
the election and um it has essentially
come down to listen
the election was we know the election
was rigged because because we did it
uh that that is where we have
fundamentally fallen here and uh meadows
should be investigated his wife should
be investigated and listen i know that
none of us if you've been paying
attention to the two-tier justice system
in this country for the last decade
you would be
reasonably
situated to question
whether mark meadows will face any
consequences regardless of what he did
even if he did it even if they've got
him dead to rights
it's it's not super likely he's going to
face any real consequences meanwhile
there are people who just accidentally
voted that they weren't supposed to they
they were like i'm probably you know
parole or there were certain situations
often low-income people
who uh sometimes end up in prison you
know so we it is this entire voter fraud
thing is not only illuminating because
they are the ones doing it but they
accuse everybody else of doing it
but it's also notable because it exposes
that two-tier justice system where
despite the people getting caught
continuing to be mostly republicans
the penalties are almost completely
absent it
it's depressing i'm with you
but uh we should understand that if they
are repeatedly talking about something
we should very closely look at whether
they themselves are the ones doing it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so as we get into the spring and
eventually the summer we're going to be
talking more and more about 2022 primary
races and midterm races and just races
in general as many of you know there's
an interesting senate race happening in
ohio this is the race in which jd vance
who is the author of the book hillbilly
elegy which really wasn't a bad book but
he's gone completely off the rails jd
vance is a candidate uh trumpus josh
mandel is a candidate and at a recent
debate within this race
a physical fight almost broke out which
included you guys i'm sure anybody who's
been to a bar
knows these situations
where two i mean it's it's two men i've
never seen women do this at a bar
they start doing the thing where they
puff up it's almost like a peacock or
you know certain animals that kind of
like there's some frogs that like blow
up their chest and certain birds i don't
know if tit mice do it or what kind of
birds um they they kind of just start
puffing themselves up and start almost
chest bumping and it's kind of like a a
battle to see who will back down first
that which normally is at happening at
bars
took place at the republican primary
debate it's really really wacky the
times of israel reporting near fight at
ohio republican senate debate between
candidates josh mandel and mike gibbons
after mandel repeatedly interrupts him
gibbons accuses the former soldier
of not knowing how investments work
which was a that was a fair criticism
leading the latter to stand up and
accost his rival and we have video of
this if you're only listening
you'll have to imagine what it's like
although we'll have the clip up on our
instagram and on our tick tock these are
the front runners guys and we'll look at
polling in a moment but this is how
cartoonish and childish and pathetic
some of these races are check this out
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you watch what happens so threats
being issued now i don't know you know
you guys will have to tell me
who comes off as the alpha male in that
situation it's
it's genuinely hard for me to tell and
meanwhile jd vance who did not
participate in that but is part of this
race sat to the side thinking obviously
this really benefits me although he's
not polling that well
these are the front runners in the ohio
republican senate primary we have the
polling here
the latest here is these are average
average average
gibbons is polling 20.
mandel is at 18.7 so that's basically a
tie it's almost within the margin of
error
jd vance is down
at 11
um and two other candidates timkin and
dolan are almost where jd vance is
patel with a point and a half so that's
an interesting race and what's
fascinating about it is the least
delusional people
um
well i can't even say that the most
obviously delusional people are some of
the ones doing the best mandel is an
absolute lunatic i mean just a complete
and total lunatic and if you actually go
and look at his um political record you
see that this is uh uh just a massive
massive
um pro-trump guy
and uh he
has backed the election fraud claims of
trump he says that the 2020 election was
stolen he says if he wins he will carry
forward trump's agenda now what's funny
about that is
it's not clear trump really had an
agenda other than just
and and uh you know putting himself in
positions of power he said the trump
impeachment was a sham he will fight for
the america first agenda he says we will
soon see the evidence coming out of the
widespread voter fraud i mean that
that's like a that's verbatim what trump
says
and he's tied for first place
essentially tied for first place with
gibbons so it's a very difficult primary
to kind of make heads or tails out of
because uh so many wacky people in there
and they don't seem to be hurt by saying
and doing crazy things we'll see if the
polling in any way is impacted if
anybody is going to benefit from that
confrontation you would think it would
be jd vance although there might be
republican voters who like that and you
say no i liked gibbons before and i
liked that gibbons didn't back down or i
liked mandel before and i liked that
mandel didn't back down and they both
puffed up their chests
at this point i don't pretend to know
what republican voters are going to like
but we'll soon see it reflected in the
polling uh this is a very interesting
and important clip that i'm going to
play for you this is video of dr karen
berg
explaining to a bunch of kentucky
senators mostly white men
how fetal development works
a really really interesting clip which
the clip itself is from march 10th but
it went viral a couple days ago
um article uh in women's agenda
you were killing women senator karen
berg slams kentucky's restrictive
abortion bill i am the only woman on
this podium i am the only physician on
this podium this bill is a medical sham
it does not follow medicine it does not
even purport to listen to medicine now
kentucky senator karen berg is not only
a senator
she is also
a medical doctor and she uh i i don't
you know i would say ranted but rant has
like a negative connotation this was a
very fact-based impassioned plea
to
again what is basically just white men
deciding about abortion and what women
should be allowed to do
explaining how things actually work
let's take a listen to this explain my
novo yes ma'am
you know i'm a diagnostic radiologist
and diagnostic radiologist
historically and in many places in this
state still
do all of the first trimester ob
ultrasound
so i am extraordinarily
partially familiar with the development
of a fetus in the womb right and for you
to sit here and say that at 15 weeks a
fetus has a functional heart a
four-chamber heart that can survive on
its own is fallacious that is not true
there is no viability you know it it
i look around at my colleagues on this
committee
i am the only one men on
this podium right now i am the only
physician sitting on this podium
this bill is a medical
sham
it does not follow medicine it does not
even purport to listen to medicine
and for each and every one of my
colleagues
to be so willing
to cast and i vote
when what you are doing is putting your
finger putting your knee
putting your
a gun to women's heads you are killing
women
because abortion will continue
women will continue to have efficacy
over their own body
whether or not you make it legal
i vote no and i really
really apologize to the people in
kentucky that we are spending this much
time and this much energy when we have
families in poverty we have single
women heading households
in poverty at a higher rate than any
other group in this state
and you all are not addressing that you
all are making it worse yeah
so this has actually become i don't want
to call it a meme
but it has become a kind of uh
self-replicating talking point about 15
weeks now what's important so and the
hesitation i have to see we there's a
double-edged sword here okay and i'll
tell you what it is which is
you can address these claims
individually and say is there anything
to this 15-week heartbeat viability
thing and we'll talk about that in a
second
but sometimes the problem is if you
start engaging specifically with some of
these things
it ignores the bigger issue which is
generally speaking clueless people
making decisions about women's bodies
and particularly people who will never
have to make those decisions for
themselves because they're mostly men as
we've seen time and time again in many
of these southern states making
decisions about abortion but
let's at least explore the talking point
which is it's it's been mentioned now in
multiple states kentucky mississippi
other places the talking point is
the heart is viable
uh at 15 weeks at 15 weeks and we have
to we have to consider that and so
therefore there should be no abortion
ever allowed after 15 weeks is typically
what what they say
um
you can argue about how fully developed
the heart is at 15 weeks and i don't
mean you can argue there's one
scientific answer but you can make that
the focus
but the truth is that until week 22 or
23
um there's no fetal viability outside of
the womb
and
you know you if you you could research
this and it's widely um written about
that at that point at 23 weeks
it's very very marginal uh in terms of
fetal viability and very very low
percentage that's 23 weeks and they're
you know parroting this 15-week thing
tate reeves the mississippi governor
recently did it on
uh
recently in the in the last six months
or so there was a incident where he was
on cnn and he talked about it as well
and it's just not true but seem simply
debunking that
um
there's a question as to whether that's
even the right way
to fight these people
because there's the bigger question of
who who are they really to say about
this stuff anyway i mean it's when we
look at the some of the questions asked
yesterday
of judge katanji brown jackson during
her confirmation hearings
are there physical differences between
men and women
are babies racist
um
what is your opinion what is the
definition of a woman
or uh should some private school in
washington dc
teach from a certain book or whatever
the case may be you can argue each of
those things on the merits but it's sort
of like she's interviewing quote
interviewing to be a supreme court
justice
whatever the answer is does it really
have relevance in the field that she is
going to be in and it's sort of a
similar thing with the abortion debate
which is to some degree the individual
fights about heartbeats and viability
and all these different things
they are not really the main issue which
is these are people who want to decide
for women
what it is that they should be able to
decide for themselves and
it's not like if you win the argument
about heart development at 15 weeks
their perspective is going to be changed
so that's why a question about the kind
of wisdom of uh engaging in that i don't
know i'm curious to hear from you guys
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
we have a longtime racist caller named
troy who calls in
and he is um
parroting some of the same racist talk
about katanji brown jackson
uh including that she is not really a
judge now at the top of the show we
already looked
by
the standards set by the current nine
supreme court justices
um katanji brown jackson is more
qualified more qualified but troy
doesn't care nope there's something
about her she's not a real judge
there is no doubt that
the joe biden nominee for the
supreme court
kenya brown jackson is a joke and a
disgrace and of course the constant you
know mispronunciation of her first name
i think is is part of this entire
package
she's an activist not a real judge
and i hope the republicans continue
to
bash this woman humiliating this woman
expose this fraud
that kanina jackson is
and they need to do the same thing
is he saying kanina liberal democrats
these republicans need to do the same
exact thing
what they did to brett kavanaugh
and what they did back in the day the
clarence comes
to nila jackson brown or whatever the
whatever
yeah so anyway getting the name wrong
and the whatever her name is and she's
not a real judge this is a pretty common
uh racist trope and you all know that i
am very very careful
about calling things or people racist on
this show this caller troy has like a
five year history of calling in and
making overtly racist comments and
that's an important context to
understand
this idea of being a real judge
i had an experience with this idea uh
as as applied to a uh to a black person
back when i worked at circuit city many
of you remember when i was in high
school and at the very start of college
i worked at circuit city selling laptops
it was quite a job
and i learned a lot of things there
including how to relate to people and so
many different things
but i also saw some really ugly
racism and xenophobia firsthand we had a
manager at one point a jamaican-american
guy named lennox one of the nicest guys
and he was he was the manager he was the
manager of the store
and there was this incident where
the store would close at 9 30
and at 9 32
a customer walked in through the
employee exit so like the front doors
were already closed and this guy walks
in at 9 32 through the door that's there
for us to leave
and he grabs a dvd
and says he wants to buy it and of
course the sales systems were all shut
down it's all you know
they're they're done we're closed that
that's it and he insisted he wanted to
buy this dvd and we explained to him you
know sir we're closed that's just it and
he said get the manager
and out comes lennox and uh lennox says
sir we're closed you know that the
registers are shut off i couldn't i just
can't take your money
um you're gonna have to come back
tomorrow or buy the thing somewhere else
you know i think maybe best buys open
till 10 or whatever and the guy says
let me see the real manager there's no
way you're the manager and of course it
wasn't
definitive that what he meant is
how could this young black guy be the
manager but we all sort of looked at
each other like it seems like this is
what's going on and then eventually you
know one of the
one of the big warehouse guys came out
and just escorted the guy out almost
like security um and this idea of the
where's the real manager you're not a
real judge
it's a common trope and quite frankly
it's sickening on the bonus show today
we are going to talk about
the leah thomas swimming controversy we
are going to discuss it washington dc is
suing grubhub for allegedly using
deceptive trade practices
and mortgage rates are surging faster
than expected what will the impact be
on real estate what will the impact be
on people's rent when people rent
apartments we will talk about all of it
on today's bonus show you can sign up at
joinpacman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show you'll get the daily show without
commercials six hours earlier than we
make it available publicly and you'll
get priority when we do our david pakman
show viewer town halls all of those
benefits and more when you sign up at
joinpackman.com i will see you on the
bonus show